guys last time we're talking about
battlefield won a game I appreciate from
the outside but I actually know very
little about there is a huge fall update
I was trying to read through the notes
it is Iike it's so dense I can't even
begin to figure out what matters and
what doesn't matter so Aaron you are I
think one of our resident battlefield
one experts Jake I have no idea about
your qualifications but played a lot of
battlefield one but yeah okay I looked
at that changeless and I was like wow so
Aaron I'll start with you first what is
what are the biggest things you've
identified that they're coming with this
patch well dispatch gave a good boost to
support which i love because I always
play as support it's my favorite class
and a lot of people shy away from it
because it's a class that's a little bit
more nuanced sometimes and a little bit
tougher to kill vehicles but so here's
what they've done their LMGs their light
machine guns some of them had by pause
and some of them didn't and I feel like
in battlefield one unlike other
battlefields their light machine guns
didn't have distinct personalities so
they've done some tweaking on those and
they've made some of them better at
mid-range which is nice because it gives
you more options and they've also put a
bipod on the lightweight versions of
them so now you've got these really nice
mid-range guns that you can also put
down on a bipod and do really accurate
long-range fire previously previously
you couldn't do that and there wasn't
really a reason to pick more than one or
two of them so they rounded them out
better then they went over to their
mortars and they decreased their
accuracy by making if the wait longer
for them to become accurate so that gets
rid of the mortar spam problem that they
had before but then they also gave them
each to to smoke rounds which is really
cool because smoke in battlefield 4 good
players is very useful when you're
getting held back trying to cross a
large stretch of no man's land you can
now more reliably smoke the enemy side
of it and conceal your team when they're
running so they got buffs and which i
think is really cool then they added
some good quality life stuff so players
who have a squad leader who's not
responding to
wadd commands and they get kicked after
I think like if they don't respond for
60 seconds or something like that now
they get kicked so your squad leader is
the one telling your squad where to go
and where to fight do they get to get
kicks from the game or do they just get
demoted I guess they get demoted
somebody else what yeah that that's
pretty cool yeah cuz a lot of times
you'll get stuck with someone who's like
come on this is free experience right
here just do it I mean if you're if
you're the squad leader and you're not
giving squad commands you're just losing
experience yeah and most of the time you
just tell people to do what they were
already doing anyway yeah so yeah like
you really have to not know what you're
doing 22 not and or you can just like
aim at something and say go there and
you get points and they get points for
following it so bad squad leaders are
getting mutiny Don which is cool and the
other thing that he did Suez Canal that
map now has five flags I think it
previously had three it was their
smallest map is it this one yeah yeah so
that's that's the biggest change to a
map in the game okay um let's see but it
don't look to be like almost a couple
hundred changes yes log and you had
mentioned to me that you know you you
know a lot about this game but you look
at those notes you kind of notice
something that stood out because it
wasn't anything you were you were
familiar with it was like a ticketing
system right like people earning tickets
for certain actions which is good to
know but the game never tells you one of
the things I've always loved about
battlefield and why I think the game has
such longevity is it's such a complex
game there's things you don't know and
when you read patch notes sometimes
they've patched something you didn't
even know existed right and you learn
something so in operations mode
apparently when you take an objective
the people fleeing if you kill them you
get tickets back gotcha which I didn't
know I would always stay in fight
because conceptually I was holding back
their advance but I was actually doing
the wrong thing and I learned from these
patch notes that I was supposed to be
running for my life because you don't
want to be killed in that phase and also
the attackers can get tickets back by
killing people fleeing from them in that
phase so it's pretty cool I know learn
something new just by reading the patch
notes what's is there anything that you
guys feel like really needs to be
addressed about
that maybe it hasn't been in this patch
yeah I battlefield one of all the the
core mechanics in this game that they
really nailed I think they kind of left
their weapon customization behind they
really only had what like seven weapons
per class and they pretended like they
had more than that by just saying oh
this one has a bipod and this one as a
scope and this one's lightweight these
are things that in other battlefields
would have just been in your
customization screen and so we need a
couple more DLC s I think with a couple
more rounds of weapons for the weapon
roster to be full enough that I feel
like it's a good it's a good unlock tree
and and also those weapons feel
different enough from one another like
again in the support class I don't think
the light machine guns I don't think
each one feels distinct enough from from
each other to justify spending the war
bonds to unlock them you just find one
that you're good with and that's that's
it there anything the community is
asking for um community was asking for
some tweaks and operations which they
got because I think attackers were what
was it they were losing too much in
operations okay um which is always
interesting that's one where I think
dices get it looking at data and didn't
something similar happen with
battlefront 2 and that came out like
wasn't like I forget what mode it was
but like the Empire would win every
single time like at first or something
like that yeah and their main Walker
assault mode it was just a route almost
every single time yeah and I think that
happens when you have expert playtesters
play the game and then you put the game
in the hands of people who are not
experts of the game and they don't know
all the tricks um because it's funny I
always find stopping the behemoths to be
very difficult especially if your team
isn't cooperating but according to the
actual data the behemoths were getting
dropped real fast in operations and and
the defenders were winning all the time
so people should have a better time and
feel like the game's a little bit more
fair awesome that all sounds really good
well that wraps up our discussion about
battlefield one it's big update and
hopefully there's more to come
thank you for joining me guys